[Music]
on this monday night
rising hospitalizations among younger
canadians
one mother's anxiety over her son's
health talk about
a scary terrifying experience
plus ontario's patchwork of policies on
school closures
a secret restaurant in paris busted was
the foie gras
worth it and the vancouver canuck season
on pause
it's really incumbent upon the canucks
organization and the league to really
ensure that the situation is tightened
most of the players benched by covin
the domino effect for the rest of the
league
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin tonight in ontario where one
health region is taking new measures to
curb an alarming rise in covenanting
cases
starting tomorrow schools in peel will
close for at least 14 days
and move to remote learning the region's
top doctor says this closure is a
necessary step to protect staff and
students in peel region
with increasing case counts and the
presence of variants of concern
we need to break chains of transmission
and keep our schools
safe but ontario's other hot zone
toronto has not ordered schools to close
despite
growing calls to do so and today the
chief medical officers for toronto peel
and ottawa
issued a joint letter calling on the
province to issue
stay-at-home orders in ontario and
across much of the country
a younger demographic is getting sick
really sick
abigail beeman talks to the front-line
workers who are witnessing it it's
heart-wrenching
it's heart-wrenching as a mother matthew
cardinal's mom says he was totally
healthy before he got the uk variant
after two weeks in the icu she's
thrilled to report her son
is off the ventilator eating solid foods
and now able to move from his bed
to a chair he's 34. my family
talk about a scary terrifying
experience i don't i don't wish this
upon anybody
i just want people to to to take
any necessary precautions it's quite
disturbing of a patron to see
uh you know people in their 20s and 30s
on life support
and breathing tube in their throat
keeping them alive this is not something
that
we are used to seeing or we should
expect to see
in a country like ours cardinal is one
of 44 people with coven 19 in a
saskatchewan icu
nearly 30 are in regina further east
ontario fares the worst
reporting around 3 000 new cases each
day for the past
four days currently nearly 500 people
are in an icu with a covet related
illness
and over the past two weeks 210
ontarians hospitalized with the virus
were younger than 50. the hallmark of
this variant is that it's much more
infectious
and it's much more likely to cause
serious illness when someone becomes
infected with it dr cali barrett is one
of many calling for better protections
including vaccination for essential
workers and points out if younger people
survive the icu
there's often long-standing physical
trauma from the medical care
required the essential workers that are
keeping our cities running
are unfortunately now dying as a
consequence of covet 19
but also if they're surviving are being
named as for matthew cardinal his mom
can't wait to hug him
and wants to see him walk again i could
see the progress right now
but tomorrow i have no idea
it's one one day at a time right now and
i'm hope i'm hoping for the best
hoping for the best alongside more
families worried about younger loved
ones in hospital
abigail bieben global news ottawa
quebec's health minister says the
hospital situation in that province is
concerning
describing the icu capacity as fragile
so tonight the province is imposing
strict lockdown measures on five more
regions
south of quebec city so far there are no
new measures for montreal
those highly transmissible variants are
a major problem in bc and alberta
the b-117 variant first discovered in
the uk
is growing exponentially in those
provinces and now the p1 variant
which first emerged in brazil is surging
too
as heather eric's west reports health
officials are warning canadians
even those who have been vaccinated
about the serious risks
hospitals in bc and alberta are bracing
themselves for what could be a
devastating spring
we're now seeing the hospital and the
intensive care units are younger people
between their 40s and 50s who are having
devastating responses to these new
variants
but it's no longer just one new variant
driving exponential growth
last week a large cluster involving the
p1 variant that first emerged in brazil
was identified in the vancouver coastal
region many cases linked to an outbreak
in the ski town of whistler bc
bc health ordered the ski resort to
close as part of new restrictions to
control viral spread
we're seeing the numbers of these p-1
variants grow
faster than we are for other variants
the p-1 variant first emerged in brazil
in late december 2020.
the first canadian case was confirmed in
toronto on february
7th bc didn't report its first case
until march 9
but as of april 1 there were 379 cases
making bc a global hot spot for this
highly infectious variant
alberta health is also investigating
what it calls a significant
outbreak linked to a large employer with
multiple sites across western canada
so far three cases of the p1 variant
have been confirmed
but that number is expected to rise the
emerging data does suggest that the p1
variant causes
more significant worse disease in
younger people
worse outcomes increased
hospitalizations there is also evidence
the p1 variant virus can spread among
those that have received a covid19
vaccine
though vaccines should prevent those
infected from becoming
seriously ill there are not a lot of
direct studies on vaccine effectiveness
in p1 their lab studies and based on the
lab studies the vaccines that we have in
canada right now
do have still an ability to neutralize
the virus in terms of the antibody
response
alberta's chief medical officer of
health did not speak to the media today
her next update is scheduled for
tomorrow after the alberta government's
covet cabinet committee is scheduled to
meet
they will be discussing alberta's
rapidly increasing coveted numbers
and whether more restrictions will need
to be deployed robin
heather yorks west in calgary thanks
heather despite rampant cases of coven
19 in much of europe
the uk is emerging from nearly four
months in lockdown
daily infections have been falling
steadily since mid-january
so too have deaths and more than 31
million people have received at least
one vaccine dose but as people look
ahead to summer plans it's unclear if
trips abroad will be allowed
as crystal gomencing reports the
government is assuring people
they won't need a so-called vaccine
passport
to enjoy their desperately needed
freedom
spring is in the air and social lives
are about to blossom
on monday the 12th i will be going to
the pub myself
british prime minister boris johnson
isn't alone in wanting to celebrate a
major step in reopening
when pubs and other non-essential shops
in england
let people back in for the first time
since december
it will be business as usual no need for
a vaccine passport
on a covid status certification as we
as we prefer to to call it i think the
most important thing to say
there is absolutely no uh question of
people being asked to produce
uh certification or uh covered status
uh report when they go to the shops or
uh
to the pub garden a document proving a
person has been vaccinated
or has covid19 antibodies led to a
chorus of opposition
the government says it may be needed in
the future to allow people to safely
attend events
or to travel but nothing has been
finalized
people are being encouraged to take
regular tests
the national health service is providing
free lateral flow kits
which can provide results in about 30
minutes
the uk's chief scientific advisor
acknowledges
they're not a hundred percent a negative
doesn't mean you absolutely haven't got
it but a positive
that is useful to identify those people
who then need to isolate
feels really nice just to be able to get
out and like free fresh air
the joy of being reunited with friends
and family
is not lost on the prime minister it was
a year ago that johnson himself was
fighting for his life in hospital
with covid19 another reason for him to
celebrate with that pint
crystal gamansen global news london
in france clandestine restaurants
operating in violation of pandemic
restrictions have triggered a police
investigation
and possible charges
a hidden camera shows a journalist
posing as a guest to access one of the
mansions in paris
hosting a pop-up restaurant menus start
at more than 160 euros per person
and include champagne truffles foie gras
and lobster
the footage reveals guests weren't
wearing masks and weren't physically
distancing
there are claims government ministers
have been dining at these secret
restaurants
this will surely irk the legitimate
restaurants that have been closed since
october to help slow the spread of the
virus
the country has the fourth highest
number of cases in the world
first he fired derrick chauvin then he
testified against him
coming up the police chief's damning
testimony in minneapolis
plus the state of emergency in florida
over a toxic
reservoir and
a major donation from a major music star
you're watching global national
[Music]
more than 100 people are dead in
indonesia and east timor
torrential rains from a tropical cyclone
caused devastating flash floods and
landslides
dozens are still missing in the two
countries authorities fear the death
toll will climb
once waters recede and recovery crews
dig through the mud and debris
and in florida an environmental
emergency is unfolding
a reservoir holding back a billion
liters of wastewater
is on the brink of collapse multiple
leaks have been spotted and a retaining
wall has shifted
hundreds of people have been told to
leave their homes and crews are working
around the clock to pump out the water
the reservoir holds a mix of salt water
fresh water
waste water and fertilizer runoff
there was more damaging testimony today
in the murder trial of former
minneapolis police officer
derek chovin the doctor who tried to
revive george floyd testified
a lack of oxygen likely caused his death
but it was the words of the city's
police chief that may be critical
to the prosecutor's case jackson proskow
reports
the testimony about to give me the truth
and nothing but the truth
in a stinging rebuke the chief of the
minneapolis police broke ranks and
testified against one of his own
sanctity of life is absolutely vital
that that is the pillar
for our use of force it was chief
madaria arredondo who previously fired
derek chovin and three other officers
after george floyd's death
calling it murder monday the chief
testified chauvin's use of force
a knee on the neck for nine minutes and
29 seconds
went directly against department
training
once mr floyd had stopped resisting
and certainly once he was
in distress and trying to verbalize that
that that should have stopped over the
past week the jury has heard from other
police officers
what is your view of that use of force
during that time period
totally unnecessary who testified that
chauvin used excessive force
if your knee is on a person's neck that
can kill him
monday the court also heard from the
doctor who spent 30 minutes trying to
resuscitate floyd in hospital
we were trying to resuscitate mr floyd
dr bradford langenfeld testified that a
lack of oxygen
asphyxia likely caused floyd's death
saying he had no reason to suspect a
drug overdose
a theory chauvin's defense has raised
chauvin and the other officers did not
render first aid after floyd stopped
breathing
the defendant violated our policy in
terms of rendering aid
dr langenfeld told the court that by the
time responding paramedics began
cpr it may have been too late
approximately
10 to 15 percent decrease in survival
for every minute that cpr is not
administered
in the coming days more officers are
expected to testify
along with experts in policing and
medicine the defense will argue floyd's
death was caused by drugs or an
underlying medical condition
the prosecution will continue to hammer
away at the use of force
jackson prosco global news washington
ahead will ottawa's next budget help
women left behind in the pandemic
the weekend is donating one million
dollars to support relief efforts in
ethiopia's war-ravaged
tigre region the musician whose real
name is abel tesfaye
is the son of ethiopian immigrants in a
statement he says my heart breaks for my
people of ethiopia as
innocent civilians ranging from small
children to the elderly
are being senselessly murdered and
entire villages are being displaced
out of fear and destruction his donation
will support the world food program
the agency says it will provide
approximately 2 million meals
humanitarian access to tigre has been
severely restricted
throughout the five-month-old conflict
the impact of the pandemic on the
economy is unlike anything we've seen
before
and it has disproportionately affected
women that's why economists and labor
experts want the upcoming federal budget
to have support programs for female
workers they're calling it a
she covery effort our senior business
correspondent ann gaviola explains
[Applause]
in past recessions men's employment took
a bigger hit and women's job gains led
the recovery
but not this time when employment fell
off a cliff at the onset of the pandemic
industries dominated by women service
travel tourism events
bled jobs and many haven't come back
economist armenian coined the term
she session i think it is impossible to
have a recovery
without a she covering she says a
different kind of downturn requires
a different kind of solution one that
focuses on the so-called caring economy
the often unpaid hours of work the
majority done by women to take care of
children the elderly and those unable to
look after themselves
rolling school and daycare shutdowns
have erased decades of employment gains
for women workers
early learning and child care has to be
the centerpiece
of the next budget from the first ever
female finance minister of canada
in the first ever self-declared feminist
government of canada
the liberals have promised to create a
national child care system
needed to help parents mostly women stay
or get back into the workforce
labor market analysts say tools to allow
workers to reskill will also help
and human resource experts are calling
on ottawa to create
incentives to help employers retain
women any types of you know through eap
through through different types of
programs through wellness programs
within the workplace
if employers can be provided with the
financial means
to provide these uh these supports
within the workplace
that would really go a long way men have
returned to the labor force more quickly
but nearly half a million women remain
unemployed one hundred thousand have
dropped out of the workforce
historically the longer they stay out
the more likely they are to stay out
permanently
reducing household income and spending
productivity and tax revenue
all a major drag on any hope of a
sustainable recovery
ann gaviola global news toronto
tomorrow marks the third anniversary of
the humboldt broncos bus crash and
tonight the team's hometown has unveiled
its vision
to honor the memory of the 16 people
killed there will be a roadside memorial
and a tribute center to showcase the
spirit of the nation
in the wake of the crash the city of
humboldt will launch a national campaign
to support the cost of construction
in 2018 the broncos team was on its way
to a game when it crashed into a truck
that had run a stop sign
the canucks versus the coronavirus up
next cover 19
checks vancouver's hockey team
the vancouver canucks are at the center
of a coveted 19 outbreak
17 players are on the nhl's protocol
list
that's more than half the team some
coaches have been hit hard too
the nhl insists the season isn't over
for the team
but as eric sorensen reports the cases
are still throwing a wrench
into the schedule for a while the
all-canadian division of the nhl looked
to be getting everything right
the season was proceeding almost
uninterrupted but now the vancouver
canucks have been brought to their knees
by covet 19
from netminder braden holtby to star
forward and captain beau horvath
close to 20 canucks players and coaches
are on the league's protocol list
some are thought to be quite sick adam
gaddet's wife is herself recovering and
tweeted last week
my hubby isn't in great shape but i'm
taking good care of him
first and foremost there is concern for
the health of the canucks
and their families across the league
obviously what's happening in vancouver
is a lot more than hockey so
you know we're obviously thinking you
know we're hoping that
everyone's doing all right there are
reports the more infectious variant
first seen in brazil
is involved potentially raising new
risks for the league we're now learning
uh this may make behaviors that were
previously
accepted and safe a little bit less safe
the nhl says it remains confident that
canucks will be able to complete their
season
the league began january 13th with a
56-game regular season to run till may
8th
then the playoffs were to start up to
march 20th more than two dozen us-based
games were postponed by kovid
with other games rescheduled but then
canada was hit
starting march 22nd four montreal
canadiens games were called off
and now for the vancouver canucks four
games have been postponed so far
and there may be more the nhl is now
extending the regular season to make up
games starting the week of may 10th
and the playoffs will be pushed back
from there there is speculation the
league may have to return to a bubble
like
last summer it's really incumbent upon
the canucks organization and the league
to really
ensure that that the situation is
tightened so that it doesn't spread and
become a much bigger problem
but what has happened to the canucks is
a cautionary tale for all of us
if that can affect someone of that
physical caliber you know none of us are
at this athletic level
all of us are at risk the serious
outbreak with the canucks comes in spite
of the league doing regular testing and
following stringent protocols
a sign that the next phase of the
pandemic may be riskier than first
imagined
eric sorensen global news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday night i'm robin gill
the signs of spring are cropping up in
many parts of the country and especially
in british columbia
so we'll leave you tonight with a sunset
flyby of these beautiful cherry blossoms
they're a staple of the vancouver
landscape at this time of year
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you on friday have a great
[Music]
[Applause]
night
you